the favorite scientist really for me is
fireman because i found him entertaining
when i first read his lecture notes the
red books
and i used to take them to bed with me
and it helped me go to sleep because and
somehow i thought that if i had these
red books it would percolate and he was
so good at explaining everything in
simple terms well i always uh i've
always
love schrodinger's wave equation i can
remember in the second year university
starting off with quantum mechanics and
we started off with with schrodinger so
showing us a bit of a hero
my favorite scientist
is i think uh actually richard feynman
that's like asking me to choose my
favorite album or my favorite book or
whatever it's just very difficult to do
that there's loads of people i guess
that you know the standard ones like
feynman carl sagan
favorite scientist
is albert einstein
because he
he seemed to magic something out of
nothing
one favorite is carl sagan just because
i think he's really done a fantastic job
of inspiring a lot of people myself
included to get into astronomy and
physics the problem is i'd love to be
able to give you a wonderfully original
and unique answer but i think feynman
probably largely because in 1982 there
was a bbc program bbc horizon program
which was just an interview with with
feynman and it made such an impression
on me the way he could explain things so
carefully so concisely and yet so
entertainingly and um that really sort
of lit a fire in me for for physics so
feinman i'd say fineman not an original
answer but an honest answer not just his
pioneering work in quantum
field theory quantum electrodynamics
but also the formalisms he introduced
the idea of a path integral which is a
very technical thing to talk about
on this but but is a technique that's
used now all the time in our field
and
he was i think perhaps
probably the first person that
certainly that really understood the
media and brought science to the general
public and certainly had to pick his
books and
his lectures have had a big influence on
on me
as far as the science goes i'm amazed by
johannes kepler who managed to map out
the trajectories and figure out the
actual orbits of planets without any
calculators or anything and it was some
intensive work that he needed to do so i
was impressed by that favorite scientist
i guess would have to be newton
and why because he basically invented
science i mean you've got to take your
hat off to the guy you know he was a bit
strange but he really he invented the
entire entire branches of mathematics he
basically then was the first to apply
them to physical systems he was the
first person to really make kind of
physics type predictions so really he
was the guy who invented the whole
subject
i had to think about this and although i
have a lot of scientific heroes i don't
really pick out anyone in particular
there are lots of people who've inspired
me in the past there are lots of
historical scientific figures that i
admire greatly for their science
even though they might not have been
particularly nice human beings
there's lots of people who if i could
i'd have a conversation with
but i don't think there's one giant of
science that i would pick out
at least i haven't been able to think of
one i
thought dirac was wonderful but i went
to lectures by him and he wasn't
wonderful he was tired he was old he was
fed up and grumpy the most beautiful
scientist i know that i've worked with
is philip nauziere who is absolutely
wonderful and he he came and and teased
me all the time he get a pair of
scissors and he put a telephone wire
through it and apparently all the french
delegation at one conference
were playing games like this all the
time you know these were the most
respectable top french physicists and he
has a naughty sense of humor so i
thought he was absolutely wonderful
so those are the the my three favorites
and nausea is really way up there but
feynman was the best